We are your heroes we are
here to serve and protect you
stormfront's violation of that
special relationship of that trust is unacceptable
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my video for the boys season 2 episode 8
finale there was so much stuff that happened so
many moments and so many comic book easter
eggs so this video is going to be a little bit
longer than normal i will be doing videos for the
boys season 3. it has been renewed for season 3
so i'll explain a little bit about that at the end
of the video too if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
a new amazon giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your favorite moment
from the episode on the video careful for spoilers
for everything that happened during the episode if
you haven't seen it yet obviously so i'm just
going to number these a little bit differently
as we go along just because there's so much stuff
to cover starting at the beginning so the episode
begins with that fake vaught psa about how to
survive a super villain attack and it's so over
the top and so crazy when you actually think about
what it is they're telling people to do homelander
introduces the law quote-unquote obviously that's
a clever reference to the new metaphorical laws
and policies stormfront is trying to introduce
to america as part of her larger plot to cleanse
the world and it's just a funny acronym of
their version of duck and cover like make
it sound like something funny so people don't
really pay attention to how crazy it really is
it's very pro-gun like everyone is supposed to
have a gun in that classroom even the little
kids use anything that you can like the teacher
has a gun they tell the little kids to impale
someone on the american flag that's a metaphor
if you've ever seen one but then we meet up with
jim beaver's character who comes back we saw him
at the beginning of the season meeting with stan
edgar about trying to regulate compound v and
joking about telling the president what to do
giving him marching orders which is sort of a
long game for vaught when he yells at his wife
who's named jody that's actually a supernatural
reference jody was a character on supernatural
there were a couple other supernatural easter
eggs later in the episode too that you may have
spotted i'll point them out when we get to
that part of the video but he confesses to
them that he absolutely hates what's going on he
doesn't like the idea of compound v getting out
in public because now apparently the military
is going to get their hands on it and they're
going to start dosing soldiers with it then ice
is going to get their hands on it too if you're
not familiar with who the ice agency is they're
basically the people that handle immigration
customs border control so it's like they're
implying that stormfront's reality is coming
to pass in america they're gonna start kicking out
all the other races that she doesn't like but they
reveal that doses of compound v are being sold by
vaught now for five million a pop which is kind of
a comic book easter egg it's a bit of a discount
though from what it costs in the comics it costs
billions of dollars to manufacture which is one of
the reasons why you don't see a ton of superheroes
flying around all over the place starlight says
goodbye to her mother who gives her that cross
she's still agnostic she doesn't really believe in
god anymore but they kind of use it as a good luck
charm or a ward of protection it's meant to be
a parallel for butcher's saint christopher medal
that he got from becca that he then gives to ryan
at the end of the episode saying now your mother
can watch over you and protect you butcher and the
boys though are making contingency plans for how
to take down and neutralize each of the different
superheroes powers starting with stormfront will
use emp on her of course most of that didn't wind
up working because when they actually did get down
to fighting at the end of the episode stormfront
blew up both of their cars with all their weapons
they make some more jokes about black noir and the
almond joys he really didn't make an appearance
during the episode i'll talk about him in a second
though because there were some comic book easter
eggs that i think that they'll pay off during
season 3 some teasers that they set up then we
go to homelander and stormfront they're trying
to figure out who was popping all the heads of
the trial confirming that they weren't actually
behind it she gets super racist referring to stan
edgar giancarlo esposito's character which they
pay off later in the episode when butcher throws
her in his face like how can a black man like you
believe in turning her into america's sweetheart
when she's what she is and he confesses
that he absolutely hates her guts but he's kind
of forced to deal with her because she's good for
business right now because she's so popular and
it's all about share price with him he's being
a businessman when has it ever not been about
business in the history of america they sort of
pay that off in a really clever way by the end
of the episode too but even though homelander is
still kind of under her spell so to speak at this
point in the episode he does sound more concerned
about the rest of the seven than stormfront who's
just ready to throw them aside like black noir is
a vegetable lamplighter is a charcoal brickhead
none of that matters because now we can take
advantage of this situation to advance our cause
when homelander questions her plans though it
gets really hardcore what do we do about the other
billions of people on the planet who aren't part
of your quote-unquote master race that you want
to create with compound v she says friedrich vaude
her former husband and the founder of the company
had a quote-unquote solution for everything this
should be a pretty clear reference in your minds
even if you didn't pay attention in grade school
history class that's all about hitler's final
solution so there's no confusion about what it is
she intends to do with billions of people that she
deems to be inferior on the planet we go from
the worst couple on the show though to the most
wholesome couple starlight and huey as they're
going to try and get queen maeve to help them out
they pay off the billy joel easter eggs during the
season finally and explain why huey is so obsessed
with billy joel why keeps watching the music video
why he keeps listening to his music it all goes
back to his mom who's apparently still alive and i
definitely think they'll bring her on the show in
a future season hopefully they'll cast some really
big name actress but it's the whole idea that they
had this special connection through the music of
billy joel then one day when he was a little kid
she just took off so he's just completely stuck
on it like he's frozen in that moment when he was
a little kid the funny thing about huey's father
too he was played by simon pegg during season one
that in and of itself is a comic book easter egg
because when the boys comic book was originally
published hughie was drawn to be like simon pegg
he was basically the model for huey's character
but when it came time to make the tv show simon
pegg was too old to play huey so they just cast
him as his father it was funny to watch queen
maeve react to huey she was completely unimpressed
and she winds up calling him a twink a couple
different times even though she comes around by
the end of the episode the whole thing with queen
made that big speech about her being tired kind of
giving up because nothing ever changes that's
meant to be a comic book easter egg in the comics
queen maeve is sort of given up and just sort
of goes along with what homelander wants to do
because she just doesn't think she's going
to be able to stop him but in the comics
she does wind up eventually helping the
boys just like she does during the tv show
we finally meet back up with becca who has
gone around all over east flatbush to every
single pawn shop and finally finds butchers she
explains what happened between homelander and
stormfront taking ryan away butcher vows to help
her even though he's not completely on board with
the idea of ryan the entire episode although
he does uphold his promise to her ultimately
the whole thing with becca and butcher during the
episode is that she just hammers home to him he
cannot grow up to be like homelander and there's
this obvious arc that they're setting up for ryan
that i'll talk about in a second too when we get
to that part of the episode they start to finally
pay off some of the church easter eggs and it
just winds up being a little bit sillier than
i expected it to be they didn't completely pay off
the fresca jokes they just continued to make more
fresca jokes but they do reveal a little bit about
the relationship between the church and vaught
so stan edgar knows exactly what's going on with
the church about all their shady dealings the fact
that they have all these money scams running and
the church has all these secrets all this dirt
on superheroes and what vaude is really doing so
they both sort of have each other at their throats
but it's a business relationship and they're both
businessmen so they kind of understand each other
but at least at this part in the episode the
deep does make it back on to the seven so stan
edgar reveals that he doesn't really have any ill
feelings against the deep or a train or any other
superheroes for that matter it's really just him
running a sports team trying to put the best team
together what is the most financially profitable
team that i can assemble but they revealed the
only reason that they're not letting a train back
on at least at this part in the episode is because
stormfront is still around she's a problem but
edgar is forced to humor her and she doesn't
want a train anywhere near the 7 because she's
super racist he eve drops hears the whole thing
which causes him to turn on stormfront in the
seven getting all the info on her backstory and
leaking it from the church's archives to huey
and starlight the funny thing about this scene
too like he just shows up in the back of their car
they sort of play it for comedy they totally freak
out but you can see the whole time on huey's face
he's having flashbacks to the beginning of season
one when a train killed his last girlfriend with
his super speed like you could just see him just
clench up even though technically a train wouldn't
be able to do that to starlight because she's so
powerful homelander and stormfront tried
to have that family quote-unquote moment
with ryan at their in-universe version of
planet hollywood that's what planet vaught
is meant to be a reference to which is superhero
paraphernalia for the seven all over the place
but his powers start acting up because he's in
public he can't handle it there's so many people
he's just been isolated his whole life so he just
gets a bit agoraphobic and starts freaking out
homelander recognizes what's happening to him
because he went through something similar as
a child and flies him off to his cabin in upstate
new york he has a really nice talk with ryan he's
actually pretty genuine he clearly does want to
be a good dad to him but he doesn't know how to
do that he doesn't even know how to be a regular
human being he's still very psychotic but he's not
quite as crazy as stormfront that's the whole
thing is they want to make him seem like he's
trying to be rational when he's standing next to
stormfront because she's so over the top crazy
but then butcher has his big meeting with
stan edgar and they make their bargain
to help control homelander by taking ryan away
that's the whole pitch you can't control him when
he has ryan he's the only deterrent that you have
the only person who's powerful enough potentially
to deal with homelander if you've read the comic
books this is obviously a very big change because
in the comics there is no ryan at this point
in the story there are ways that vaught has of
dealing with homelander and plans contingencies
that they have but apparently they're not going
to do that on the tv show so it seems like they
want you to think that ryan will ultimately be
their long-term plan for controlling homelander
they have that funny moment with homelander
and stormfront trying to teach ryan how to use
his heat vision on a doll of the deep which is
obviously funny for a couple reasons one because
it's so the way they're trying to teach him
but mostly because homelander also wanted to
laser the deep a couple times during season one
stormfront also goes way over the top trying to
brainwash ryan with her whole rhetoric about
white even homelander is confused by what
she's trying to shovel into ryan like did you
just say that doesn't make any sense i think when
it comes to stormfront even homelander as crazy
and twisted as he is understands that naz*s are
fundamentally bad he learned that in everything
that they believe in is bad so stormfront is bad
but he's just so thirsty for human connection in
someone to love him that he just kind of ignores
a lot of his own thoughts on the matter and i
love how she's trying to be super motherly in a
very evil sinister way but then on a dime drops
an f-bomb when she gets the alert about the news
of her in the secrets leaking out to the press
people start memeing her the same way that she was
memeing homelander at the beginning of the season
she completely loses it the car you'll notice
that runs over her in the meme is actually a
black impala that's another supernatural easter
egg they're actually ending that show right now
jensen ackles actually bought that car in real
life and he's going to be playing soldier boy
during the boys season 3 so there's just a lot of
supernatural easter eggs in and around the series
the funny follow-up to this scene too is when
homelander catches the news with ryan you notice
that he's drinking another glass of milk i think
this is the final glass of milk that we have
during season two but i'm sure he'll be drinking
more milk during season three he probably has
a whole fridge that's just milk but then the
boys set off their plan to snag ryan using an
ultrasonic noise device built by vaught that only
affects animals and people with super sensitive
hearing like homelander and ryan they grab him
but homelander realizes when seeing the vault logo
that edgar is behind this trying to take ryan away
from him press f in the chat for all those guards
because clearly butcher sacrifices them knowingly
because he leaves the phone there so they show up
and they give themselves away when they call
his name out did you just say the name butcher
he goes full american psycho on them lasers
the first guard and then just walks out later
just leaving you wondering what he did to the rest
covered in their gore but then stormfront shows
up stopping them from escaping by throwing the
car with her lightning attack they had a couple
really cool special effects during the episode
they have a big standoff with starlight kimiko
and the boys and you kind of see what they're
doing with her big speech about spinning the
truth to fit her narrative like what is truth
really when anyone will believe whatever i say
kimiko isn't quite able to defeat her on her own
but she does have a real badass moment when she
twists her own head around back on straight just
because of the way her compound v powers work
the thing about compound v and they kind of
referenced this a little earlier in the episode is
that voc can actually use compound v to bring
dead superheroes back to life no joke but when
they do that the risen usually come back as
mindless zombie-like versions of themselves
shells really that was kind of what they were
referencing when they were saying that black
noir is alive but he's kind of a vegetable
and they can't really tell this also might
have something to do with what happens to
stormfront at the end of the episode as well
based on the speech that homelander gives to the
press i'll explain that in a second but stormfront
goes full emperor palpatine star wars with her
lightning blast she even kind of has her own
version of a star wars anakin skywalker revenge of
the sith darth vader moment too on mustafar when
she gets the classic anakin skywalker burns all
over her body and loses a bunch of her limbs all
we needed here was for ryan to say i have the high
ground it's over anakin i have the high ground
but it takes queen maeve showing up to help them
out to take her down they have this big girl fight
team up against her and they pay off that avengers
end game girls get a done joke from their justice
league unite the 7 movie that they were doing
earlier this season like frenchie even literally
says girls really do get it done when becca stabs
stormfront's eye out too that's another big comic
book easter egg stormfront lost his eye because
he was a man in the comics when butcher and the
boys start laying into him they pay off the whole
heat vision training scene that ryan had earlier
in the episode with the line about protecting the
ones you love from people who want to hurt them
only now it's stormfront that's trying to hurt
his mother because ryan doesn't totally understand
how to use his powers he just gives off this
giant hundred percent area of effect blast to
neutralize her but in doing so accidentally kills
his mother becca the idea of collateral damage is
a big thing during the boys comic book remember
at the beginning of the season 2 when they were
talking about collateral damage the amount of
collateral damage that compound v superheroes
cause in the world of the boys is on average over
30 super high mostly because very few of them
understand how to use their powers just like ryan
has no idea how to use them butcher says his final
goodbyes and just as she dies he almost goes for
ryan with the crowbar you can see for just a brief
second and that's another big comic book easter
egg so in the comics butcher finds his wife
dying after he thinks that homelanders had
his way with her and because of his super dna
she gets pregnant on the spot and the baby just
grows super fast in her womb emerges with super
powers but just as it does comic book butcher
kills the baby before it can get any bigger
homelander kind of loses it a little bit in
sadness when he sees what happened to stormfront
obviously he cared about her even though i think
in reality he recognized how terrible she was
she's on the edge of death and she's so delirious
from pain that she starts speaking in her native
german tongue as if she's back in world war ii
then homelander and butcher have another standoff
just like at the end of season one with butcher
threatening to kill everyone if homelander
doesn't back off you start to see homelander go
crazier and crazier he's sort of descending more
into villainy and he has another american psycho
type moment when he's covered in blood laughing
maniacally it takes queen maeve threatening to
release the airplane video to get him to back
off and promise to leave starlight and the rest
of the boys alone i love the sound editing here
too when you can hear the crowd chanting his name
before they transition and maeve says no one will
ever love you again he realizes that he cares
more about that feeling than getting revenge on
the boys then at the press conference later edgar
pins everything that's happened including the head
popping on stormfront homelander lies apologizing
for not realizing how evil she was sooner but when
homelander says stormfront is being held in an
undisclosed location and will pay for her crimes
that might also be a reference to compound v
zombies from the comic book when the camera starts
to zoom in on his eyes and the audio starts to go
out that seems like it's meant to be a reference
to alfred hitchcock's psycho where norman bates is
sitting in the prison cell and the camera starts
to zoom in on him and he goes full blown psycho
so i think this is them just pushing homelander
more in a villain direction heading into season
three mother's milk winds up getting back with his
family finally they pay off frenchie and kimiko's
relationship as they go dancing together butcher
finally sees ryan off heading into government
protection with becca's saint christopher medal
and they have one of the most twisted homelander
scenes ever so this is him jerking off on top of
the empire state building going on and on
i can do whatever i want whatever i want
seeming like he's totally and completely lost it
this was actually meant to be a scene that they
did during season one but amazon actually wouldn't
let them do it they said that it was too crazy
and probably the biggest of the episode is
that just as the leader is bargaining with the
congresswoman to gain tax-exempt status for the
church she pops his head revealing that it was
actually her behind the head popping incident in
the courtroom huey winds up joining her office of
superhero affairs inside the government they're
supposedly going to be regulating superheroes in
compound b but here's the thing she would have to
be connected to vaught and edgar on the dl because
all superheroes remember are made by vaude vaught
is very meticulous about tracking everyone with
compound v in their bodies their ultimate goal is
getting power inside the white house taking over
the government in what better way to rig that game
than if they themselves were secretly running the
government agency that was supposed to be watching
them it doesn't confirm that she's working for
edgar but she probably has connections to him
so obviously that's going to be a big story line
during season three and they are writing it right
now they won't start filming season three episodes
till february so hopefully they get episodes
out by the end of next year i hope we don't have
to wait till 2022 before getting new episodes
but if you spotted any big easter eggs in the
episode that i didn't mention in the video just
write them below in the comments i'll do another
boys season 3 episode in the next couple of days
as well the next big thing that's coming up is
the mandalorian season 2 episodes that's gonna
start in a couple weeks i'll be doing episode
videos for that as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see all those videos
but everyone click here to learn about doctor
strange showing up in spider-man 3 and then doing
a bunch of live-action spider-verse stuff and
click here for the brand new star wars mandalorian
season 2 trailer video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!